is that why you don't cheat because
you're just badass yeah well hold on I'm
bad at sex I'm bad at everything yeah me
too that's why I don't know how do you
know you can't because I've done it I've
been there every time
yeah the best note are you gonna put it
in and you thought it was in I thought
I'd already have an orgasm
[Laughter]
in the bed that's the first time I lost
my virginity
uh second time was uh right after it
when I went in with a compromised condom
a compromy
she says are you gonna put it in I'm
like oh yeah yeah yeah yeah and that's
when I lost my virginity you haven't got
them on and then came between the bed
sheets
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah filled up I
thought it was too different no no no no
no no no no no no no no it's the same
night
I'm introduced to sex in my life